[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté pour
donc la fin de notre série de débats
consacrés aux élections législatives
2022 en franche-comté 12
circonscriptions sur france 3 franche
comté et bien 12 débat et nous terminons
ce soir avec la première circonscription
du doubs celle de besançon planoise qui
compte aussi saint vite qu'un jet ou
encore aux 2es buissière aux dernières
législatives en 2010 est la députée
socialiste sortante barbara romagnan
avait été battue par la macro nist
fanette charvier qui faisait ses tout
premiers pas en politique fanette
charvier ne se représente pas cette
année et donc sa succession est très
ouverte emmanuel macron est arrivé en
tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle avec 28 % des voix devant
jean luc mélenchon qui a recueilli
24 % des suffrages et c'est son meilleur
score en franche comté voici donc les
cinq candidats qui vont débattre durant
plus d'une heure à propos donc de leur
programme de leurs propositions pour
cette 1ère circonscription du doubs tout
d'abord laurent croizier vous êtes
adhérents modem et conseiller municipal
d'opposition vous porter des couleurs de
ensemble le parti de la majorité
présidentielle face avoue séverine 16e
vous êtes de la france insoumise et vous
avez reçu l'investiture de la nuque donc
l'alliance donc des partis de gauche nul
ça veut dire nouvelle union populaire
écologistes écologique et sociale thomas
lutte à vos côtés est conseiller
régional du rassemblement national
fabrice galpin vous vous porter les
couleurs de reconquête le parti d'eric
zemmour et puis salim a signé à rennes
vous êtes conseillère régionale du prg
le parti radical de gauche bonjour nous
avions également invité michel vinet qui
est le candidat des républicains
conseiller départemental malheureusement
michel vianey et souffrons et ne peut
pas participer à ce débat donc d'autres
candidats sont en lice dans cette 1re
circonscription du doubs je vous laisse
découvrir leur nom et leur formation
politique c'est la circonscription de
franche comté qui totalise le plus de
candidats douze au total j'ajoute que
des citoyens
et pour leur engagement syndical ou
associatif vous poseront également des
questions portant sur la sécurité
l'éducation ou encore l'environnement et
puis à peu près 20 minutes avant la fin
de ce débat interviendra notre confrère
claude bruillot qui est journaliste à
france bleu besançon il interviendra en
fin d'émission donc pour poser quelques
questions à nos candidats vous pouvez
commenter et réagir à ce débat sur
twitter grâce au hashtag cirque ou 25 01
donc la première question va être posée
donc à nos candidats l'ordre de passage
a été tiré au sort et c'est laurent
croizier du modem ensemble qui ouvre le
bal alors vous êtes monsieur face à une
tâche difficile garder cette
circonscription dans le camp
présidentiel n'est ce pas une marche
implose pour excusez moi l'expression
un simple conseiller municipal
d'opposition
merci pour la question madame même série
comme ça ça vous donne envie de
réfléchir deux secondes pour y répondre
l'ensemble des candidats autour de la
table si si nous nous sommes engagés si
je me suis engagé dans la vie publique
c'est pour agir et si le président de la
république m'a apporté sa confiance
c'est pour mon expérience justement mon
expérience d'élu local j'ai su reconnu
comme un élu de terrain donc je serai
évidemment 1 et lutte un député de de
terrain et pas seulement en période
d'élection je suis reconnu comme un élu
qui est je vous donne juste un tout
petit conseil aux uns et aux autres ne
mangez pas tout votre temps de parole
dès la première question gardé dans un
petit peu pour s je serai je suis un élu
un élu proche des habitants je serai un
député proche des habitants voilà c'est
la force de mon expérience justement de
bélus locale qui va faire qui va nourrir
mon expérience de futurs députés et j'ai
de l'ambition pour mon territoire et
cette ambition j'ai bien attention de la
porter à l'assemblée nationale fabrice
vial pardon pour reconquête le parti
d'eric zemmour vous vous êtes
actuellement adjoint de marie-france ses
fils maire de droite de valdoie dans le
territoire de belfort et puis vous êtes
candidat ici dans le doubs un pied d'un
côté un opinion vous nous expliquer et
pittoresque je vous explique tout
simplement parce que j'habite et valdoie
pendant plusieurs années
au moment des élections je m'étais donc
présenter parce que je devais rester sur
belfort puis mutation professionnelle je
travaille déjà depuis 11 ans sur
besançon je suis venu m'installer sur
besançon doubs vous n'êtes plus cinglant
vous n'êtes plus adjoint hadji suis
encore mais je vous cache pas que je
risque de démissionner sous peu
élections ou pas élections au bon bien
sûr ans séverine vieillesse donc vous
êtes investis par la nuque la gauche est
majoritaire à besançon elle a même
remporté la ville il y a deux ans avec
une coalition écolo socialiste
communique communiste mais sans les
mélenchonistes puisque vous vous avez
présenté une liste contre cette gauche
là est ce que vous pensez tout a été
décidé apparaît dans les états-majors
que ici localement ou n'oublie tout non
n'oublie pas tous localement et puis on
vous oubliez aussi un épisode 1 c'est
l'épisode des régionales et
départementales où on a fait un vrai
travail et j ai participé en première
ligne pour faire une liste de
rassemblement il ya eu des difficultés
mais il ya eu des endroits où ça a pu
fonctionner et puis là je voudrais dire
qu'on est néanmoins dans une élection
nationale on est dans un moment
historique
les plus jeunes d'entre nous n'ont
jamais connu un tel rassemblement de la
gauche depuis plus de 25 ans 1997 où on
a cinq forces politiques parti
socialiste parti communiste
europe ecologie les verts génération et
la france a soumises qui se sont réunis
dans toutes les circonscriptions de
france avec pour objectif de faire face
à emmanuel macron est de proposer une
autre majorité et c'est seulement un
moment historique qu'il faut souligner
je suis très fière d'être la candidate
de ce rassemblement salies mane les
arènes vous vous êtes donc du parti
radical de gauche la gauche c foot quand
elle représentée ici par séverine
vieillesse de la dupe est ce que votre
candidature ne reste ne risque pas de
faire perdre votre camp
non je suis de gauche oui mais la gauche
du réel on n'est pas obligé de se
soumettre à l'extrême gauche j'ai des
convictions des valeurs et je pense que
je refuse de m'asseoir sur des valeurs
fondamentales pour avoir un siège il ya
un électorat qui aujourd'hui ne trouve
pas de réponse à l'offre proposée
aujourd'hui sur cette première
circonscription depuis je suis en
campagne avec didier aubry j'entends
heureusement que vous présentez on ne
savais pas pour qui voter donc il faut
donner le choix du vote aux électeurs
des premiers tours pour une candidature
telles que celles que je représente
thomas lüthi du rassemblement national
les multiples fractures à l'inter de
votre famille politique font que les
candidats se suivent et se ressemblent
pas en plus dans une ville qui est peu
convaincu par le rassemblement national
est ce que votre candidature c'est une
candidature de témoignage mais je pense
que mon engagement également dans la
politique depuis plus d'un an même au
conseil régional où j'ai pu prendre mes
marques et montrer à quel point nous le
groupe du rassemblement travail parce
que celles qui travaillent le plus
aujourd'hui à la région effectivement
fait que on peut venir de la société
civile être à la tête d'une entreprise
même de plusieurs entreprises et prendre
encore le temps de s'engager
politiquement pour effectivement porter
les valeurs d'un mouvement qui sert
peut-être a connu quelques fractures et
quelques désistements mais qui a quand
même montré une dynamique aux dernières
élections avec des progressions qui font
envie à beaucoup d'autres partis donc je
reste confiant et je me lance dans la
bataille naturellement pour arriver en
tête vous vouliez répondre à monsieur
lutz que je vous ai vu réagir en tant
que conseillère régionale oui le groupe
et rennes travail je ne dénie pas mais
je crois pas que ce soit le groupe les
travaille le plus la majorité est active
et fourni de gros efforts pour être
présente sur le terrain sur tous les
dossiers au quotidien plus près des
habitants mais du coup ça vous pose pas
trop problème de dire que la candidature
de la nuque et d'extrême gauche alors
que concrètement vous siégez avec le
parti communiste et le parti socialiste
à la région qui font partie des deux
partis qui le soutiennent ah non je dis
pas l'extrême gauche je parle de tourner
alors je vais préciser la lsi et deux
extrêmes ou chez vous est la candidate
du ps avec l'étiquette et les filles je
suis la candidate de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale qui le
rassemblement de la gauche et d'écologie
gauche a totalement raison et quand vous
parlez de vos valeurs que vous ne
trouviez pas dans la nuque vous parliez
de quoi l'europe déjà je crois qu'on a
une vision complètement différente de
l'europe aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire et la guerre en qui
qui est actuellement en ukraine je crois
qu'on a besoin d'une europe forte qui
s'oriente vers une europe de la défense
qui nous permet d'asseoir une volonté
européenne
et une vision européenne qui nous
permettra aussi d'être moins dépendants
de nos alliés et de pouvoir apporter des
réponses une europe il faudra bien
évidemment orienté vers une europe du
social et une europe
plus humaine vous voulez réagir je fasse
je suis enseignante de droit européen
donc autant vous dire que je connais
très bien le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes et que je suis
fondamentalement pro européenne pour la
construction européenne par contre je ne
suis pas pour le repos des marchés et je
ne suis pas pour cette europe qui s'est
assis sur le référendum de 2005 qui a
refusé une bonne partie des dispositions
qui ont été remis dans le traité de
lisbonne en 2007 l'europe actuellement
est malade souffre d'un déficit de
démocratie souffre d'une abstention et
effectivement il va falloir qu'on agisse
pour maintenir cette construction
européenne mais orienté la construction
européenne vers une europe sociale et
une europe au service des peuples
laurent croizier vous êtes certainement
autour de cette table le plus pro
européen vous dites quoi je la suis moi
je suis la candidature la plus favorable
à la construction européenne
je suis un mouvement démocrate et s'est
bâti aussi sur sur ces deux valeurs ce
que je dis c'est que aujourd'hui les
conflits ukrainien aujourd'hui après la
période de vide que nous avons traversée
je crois que là la question européenne
elle ne souffre plus il ne souffre de
plus de plus d'aucune question quoi
c'est oui le repas été forte pendant que
vida nous a permis d'avoir accès à des
vaccins aujourd'hui l'europe a été forte
sur pour lutter contre
le l'inflation va dire de l'énergie on
sent que aujourd'hui il ya des des
difficultés mondiales 1 par rapport à
l'europe aujourd'hui à asus mobiliser je
prends là par exemple la taxe de 15%
minimal sur les impôts sur les
entreprises aujourd'hui en europe moi je
suis fier que l'euro ps et se soit saisi
de cette question pour que lyon ait des
entreprises qui payent des impôts en
europe il n'ya pas que le chargeur
unique pour tous les appareils
telefonica ordinateur vous vouliez dire
qu'il pouvait alors je remercie déjà ma
voisine d'avoir rappelé à ceux qui
avaient oublié qu effectivement les
partis démocrates se sont largement un
fish sur le référendum populaire un des
rares référendum qui avait eu qui fait
que tous vos petits familles sont allées
voter ce que les français avaient rejeté
le moins bon de parler d' europe
solidaire d'europe de la défense mais
les allemands viennent bien acheter des
fn aux américains au lieu de prendre nos
rafales ont parlé d'une europe qui
permet d'acheter moins cher mais on est
face à une crise de l'énergie que vous
avez passé maîtrisé vous ne parlez une
europe des vaccins mais l'angleterre qui
est fr vidéo sortie de route pardon à
vacciner bien davantage que nous bien
avant nous pour un coût moindre donc si
vous voulez l'europe est totalement
faillite vous essayer de la maintenir
les faits sont là ils parlent d'eux
mêmes c'est un voeu peut défier de faire
quelque chose de bien et en matière de
défense pour var était peut-être sur
leur prochain vrai bien qu'on vienne
vous avez sûrement un mot à dire
monsieur galpin alors - l'europe mais
rapidement on jouera bien le monde
vienne au thème de la sécurité alors moi
pour l'europe tout simplement je suis
pour pour une souveraineté française et
donc pas pour l'europe ça vous le rêve
on l'aura compris c'est un programme d
d'eric zemmour je pense qu'en france on
peut avoir on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
avoir une et une indépendance française
et retrouver notre souveraineté on va
faire un premier tour de table si vous
le voulez bien propos de la sécurité on
parlera de la police après un premier
tour de table dans votre circonscription
se trouve planoise 18000 habitants le
quartier le plus difficile de besançon
peut-être même de franche comté ce
quartier fait malheureusement la une de
la presse y compris nationale pour cetef
trafic de drogue pour ces règlements de
compte ses morts par balles alors
comment améliorer la sécurité dans ce
quartier quelles sont vos propositions
concrètes rapides vous aviez
d'apparaître la parole je vous la laisse
monsieur galpin et après on parle des
pôles ici on vient pas tout de suite sur
ce sujet là alors je pense d'abord qu'il
faut un réhabiliter le quartier
aujourd'hui les gens ont peur d'y aller
malheureusement
on ne voit que planoise comme un
quartier sombre et je suis persuadé
qu'on avoir rencontré qu'il ya aussi des
gens très bien je pense qu'il faut
réinstaller les commissariats de
proximité qui ont été fermées il ya
quelques années il faut les réinstaller
il faut les renforcer il faut sur toute
la discussion il faut je pense employer
plus de personnes pour avoir une
ouverture sur planoise mais quand on dit
plus de personnes c'est quoi céder des
policiers éducateurs et éducateurs catr
des policiers je pense qu'il faut faire
du social dans ce quartier effectivement
du social aussi pour vous monsieur lutte
peut-être là on va en voir la fracture
entre les deux parents je la droite de
la droite est restée sur la ligne
naturellement notre notre engagement
depuis des années je pense que du social
on en fait un c'est donner d'argent au
quartier soul et la région fait 40
millions sur sept quartiers qu'est-ce
qu'on mois fait convard payer des
crèches par payer et ainsi de suite ça
ne change rien les dealers de drogue ou
encore mille feux il ya quelques années
à cassen fins privées tous les habitants
de leur centre pour faire les courses
donc non nous maintenant c'est très
clair je veux dire beaucoup de choses
ont été faites beaucoup d'argent et
déversé aujourd'hui c'est faire
appliquer la loi donc effectivement des
moyens de police on va en parler c'est
des caméras fait que la mairie également
prenne ses responsabilités et puis
également derrière une réponse pénale
très forte c'est les choufs les dealers
s'élève enlevé immédiat les choses ce
sont les guetteurs oui mais voilà j'ai
traduit oui donc effectivement toute
personne étant délinquants et un reconnu
avec des vagues de délinquance important
doit être effectivement le sanctionner
et puis ne plus rester dans ce quartier
qu'effectivement pourrit la vie des
autres salies mane les arènes mais quel
dommage de parler de planoise simplement
sous l'angle de la sécurité c'est le
plus grand foyer de population de la
circonscription
on va leur mettre une étiquette alors
qu'il ya tellement de choses qui sont
faites et c'est qu'on ne peut pas mal au
sénat par lescott planoise mais c'est
quand même le ces dernières années c'est
quand même là où il ya eu des morts par
balles à cause du trafic et de demande à
ce que les habitants qui y vivent sont
les premières victimes
des problèmes de sécurité ça déjà c'est
un premier point deuxième chose
effectivement on peut regretter
démantèlement de la police de proximité
mais parler de sécurité dans ces
quartiers il faut aussi parler de
prévention effectivement que ce soit les
éducateurs que ce soit les médiateurs
que ce soit le soutien aux associations
notamment des soutiens aux associations
d'éducation populaire qui font un
travail énorme est conséquent mais qui
n'est pas suffisant je pense aussi qu'il
faut absolument arrêter cette
vision anglais sur ce quartier parce que
les gens en souffrent moi j'ai vécu
jusqu'en 2019 dans un quartier populaire
pour vous dire que des gens sont en
souffrance ce sont ceux qui habitent
monsieur les premières à leur victime
laurent croizier que faut-il faire
concrètement précisément pour améliorer
la sécurité à planoise c'est tout un
panel de décisions 1 il faut revoir la
rénovation urbaine a en tout cas il ya
un gros investissement de 180 millions
d'euros qui sont qui sont alloués sur
cette rénovation urbaine de planoise
donc on a des bâtiments qui son bourreau
des gros ensembles qui sont beaucoup
trop gros on a un problème d'éducation
ça a été dit à planoise ce sont les
écoles les plus grosses du département
dans un quartier qui a énormément de
besoins en matière scolaire c'est
absolument anormal je milite moins à
l'échelle de besançon pour qu'on
reconstruise il n'aurait laissé la
planoise faut plus de policiers et
ensuite il faut recruter des policiers
alors depuis 2010 est à l'échelon
national 10000 postes de policiers ont
été créés dans la circonscription de
sécurité publique de besançon ces 84
policiers nationaux maintenant il faut
mettre plus de bleus sur le terrain
comment comme on dit de bleu ça veut
dire plus jennifer de dire plus
d'uniformes sur le terrain on a un poste
de police à peine trois mois je souhaite
qu'il devienne un commissariat je
souhaite qu'on ait beaucoup plus de
patrouilles dans les rues ça va rassurer
la population qui le demandent ça m'est
insupportable de voir que le mercredi on
a des jeunes qui jouent au ballon entre
les dealers donc un moment donc quelques
éducation fermeté ont fait respecter les
lois de la république séverine vs pour
la nuque alors déjà je pense qu'il faut
changer le postulat de départ qui est de
voir les quartiers populaires que sous
l'angle de la sécurité nos quartiers
populaires c'est une grande richesse une
richesse dont les habitants sont mm leur
quartier les habitants de planoise quand
on parle avec eux ils aiment leur
quartier effectivement ce sont les
premières victimes de cette de cette
insécurité moi je pense qu'il faut
réorienter
comment dire la politique de maintien de
l'ordre qui est faite notamment sur
planoise il faut arrêter de courir après
les petits consommateurs par exemple est
véritablement avoir une lutte contre les
trafiquants contre les trafiquants de
drogue contre les trafiquants d'armes
parce que ce sont eux qui pourrissent la
vie et qui sont la racine du problème
évidemment qu'il faut aller en soutien
aux associations d'éducation populaire
et puis il ya une grande problématique à
ham à planoise dont souffrent les
habitants c'est la privatisation de
l'espace public par des petits groupes
et il faut absolument que son conte ce
que la population se réapproprie ces
espaces et qui ces petits groupes baisse
et de céder petit groupe qui est vont
effectivement par leur comportement
privatiser et empêché certaines
personnes notamment dans les halls
d'immeuble ou même dans sur les places
etc et je pense véritablement qu'ils ne
sont pas tous des dealers les y en a
forcément mais il y en a effectivement
mais encore une fois la racine du
problème c'est les trafiquants les
trafiquants droit et c'est là qu'il faut
mettre les moyens mais on l'accompagné
je finis juste il faut accompagner la
population et mener des projets dans le
quartier de planoise pour qui les
rapproche réappropriation de l'espace
public et ça c'est fondamental et puis
dernier point on parle de rénovation
urbaine les planes oisiens et les planes
asian souffre d'une chose c'est qu'on ne
les associe pas suffisamment aux prises
de décisions de souligner ou qui ne les
a pas sifflé aliments alors on va les
écouter voilà laurent croizier le à
votre soutient madame madame géniaux je
ne manque pas n'hésitez pas à lui dire
parce que je le répète elle a
semble-t-il elle n'a pas compris
j'aimerais des accords madame vieillesse
avec vous c'est que n'y aurait pas de
trafiquants de drogue qui avait pas de
consommateurs donc moi je pense qu'il
faut pénaliser beaucoup plus les
consommables on a un vrai désert on a un
vrai désaccord et consommer des
stupéfiants
ses deux complices me madam veilleuse
ses deux complices des trafiquants sept
complices de la violence et public les
yeux complices de l'insécurité qui
gangrène nos quartiers une question de
santé publique messieurs est complice de
l'assombrissement de l'avenir de nos
jeunes qui tombent dans les trafics nous
sommes un des pays qui sommait plus dur
sur ces questions là est mauvais en
termes de prévention monsieur m'a même
pas si on ne résout pas du tout le
problème comme ça c'est une question il
chantait public consommateur il faut
remettre il faut remettre la prévention
et de la lutte contre les ati donner de
l'espoir si si votre espoir que vous
donner c'est unir aux jeunes d'aller
favori consommateurs ou lire et le réel
normal mon espoir c'est de sortir les
consommateurs des adhésions et je
l'eusse une lettre juste une petite
question dans vos dans la nuque il ya
europe écologie qui est pour la
légalisation du viol à bord sera on
portera en effet la légalisation du
cannabis mais c'est un bonheur et
victoire avec nous ce n'est le barrio
tradi clore au contraire parce que
l'idée c'est vraiment de mener une
politique de prévention et de lutte
contre les addictions y compris ou y
compris au sein de l'école et de tarir
d'enlever la racine du problème en
s'attaquant véritablement aux
trafiquants monsieur galpin réintervenir
jeu d'abord je suis très surpris
d'entendre le même business de donner
des leçons de morale alors que ses
équipes par exemple cole les affiches
d'un homme béziers est sûre mais affiche
depuis hier donc ça ça me je trouve ça
complètement anti républicain donc c'est
des belles leçons de valeur oui
d'ailleurs j'ai pu déposer plainte ce
matin contre votre parti pour le 16 go
affichant monsieur mais je peux vous
répondre mais après ce match ceci et
quant à planoise je pense
qu'effectivement il faut faire du social
mais on doit faire avant de la
prévention et si il n'y a pas de
prévention et bien à ce moment s'il y a
de la prévention pardon et qu'elle n'est
pas établie à ce moment là effectivement
nous pourrons sanctionné alors je
voudrais qu'on fasse qu'on fasse un
petit peu avancer ce débat je vous
propose maintenant d'écouter un
syndicaliste de la police il vous
interroge mesdames et messieurs
justement cette somme c'est un un
syndicaliste donc d'alliance le syndicat
des policiers eux doutent de la police
nationale ont l'écoutent à propos de la
présomption de légitime défense
notre pays est exposé à une montée en
puissance de la violence les policiers
sont en première ligne et sont
malheureusement parfois contraints de
faire usage de leurs armes avec pour
conséquence d'être immédiatement présumé
coupable alliance police nationale
demandent la reconnaissance de la
présomption de légitime défense pour nos
policiers quelle est votre position sur
ce sujet
donc je vous rappelle un fait
d'actualité qui a eu lieu ce week end à
paris un contrôle qui tourne mal entre
des policiers et une voiture il y aurait
eu un refus d'obtempérer les policiers
tirent il ya un mort un blessé grave les
trois policiers placés en garde à vue
ont été relâchées le sans aucune charge
retenue contre eux l enquête se poursuit
et nous avons interrogé donc emmanuel
pas avant ce fait divers dramatique de
paris monsieur galpin pont ou contre la
présomption de légitime défense alors je
te d'abord comme je connais très bien
emmanuel pain puisque mon métier
aujourd'hui ma m'amène à travailler à
tous chaque semaine au commissariat de
besançon et je discute de tout de tous
ces soucis avec les fonctionnaires de
police je veux d'abord faire un bilan de
l'année des cinq dernières années ou
sur l'heure tourne il faut qu'on avance
il ya eu des violences sexuelles en
augmentation de 33% c'est inacceptable
il ya aujourd'hui 120 attaques à l'armé
blanche par jour et aujourd'hui nos
fonctionnaires de police ne sont plus
crédibles moi ce que je veux c'est leur
redonner de la valeur leur donner du
sens et bien évidemment leur donner la
présomption de légitime défense
présomption de légitime défense je me
tourne du côté du rassemblement national
mac ou de madame vérif était dans le
programme c'était un des points
importants effectivement ça souligné qu'
on a eu quatorze mille refus
d'obtempérer sur les zones police est
très évident entre gendarmes et c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus le
policier qui fait force de loi celle
délinquance est effectivement rappelé à
paris cette personne qui n'a ni permis
ni papier et qui se permet de rouler sur
les forces de l'ordre donc effectivement
nous attendait l'enquêté est en cours on
le fait en cours mais enfin les caméras
ont révélé fera donné voici n'ai pas lu
les imaginer ou pour que le procureur
dit qu'effectivement il ne retient pas
de charge après avoir visionné les
caméras bon je ne suis pas d'intrus dans
l' enquête mais disons que je fais
également confiance au personnel de
police qu'on métier très très difficile
et que nous nous soutenons
voyez tant que ces gens là ne pourront
pas faire leur métier sans avoir peur
c'est à dire vraiment faire leur métier
c'est eux qui ont la loi je suis quand
même étonné en plus de la part de deux
de ses de ces voyous j'allais dire
qu'ils viennent de certains pays ou par
contre là la police j'allais dire vous
dirais même dessus avant vous ayez pu
mettre ses mains sur le volant voyez -
avec le titan que j'ai fait dans la
marine nationale je suis allé en turquie
je suis allée en egypte sur les dans de
nombreux pays comme cela vous ne
rigolait pas avec la bri il ya que chez
nous où on peut se permettre
effectivement de s'en prendre à la
police c'est intolérable salima in the
rain parce que chez nous rien contre 6
et heureusement que la république vous
écoutez je vous ai pas interrompu s'il
vous plaît merci alors pour ou contre
cette présomption de j'aimerais avant
quand même remettre quelque chose en
plus en perspective la police nationale
comme je le disais donc on est en
république la démocratie fait partie des
services publics et en tant que tel il
doit être défendu d'autant plus que ils
sont en charge la sécurité la protection
des personnes et du respect de la loi
ceci étant posé ils ont un devoir
d'exemplarité en tant que fonctionnaires
sont aussi fonctionnaire donc vous êtes
contre la légitime alors se retourner
contre la victime de ce que nous avons
un cadre la présomption d'innocence il
enquête si faute il y a il doit y avoir
sanction comme tout à chacun moi je suis
désolé je suis fonctionnaire je dois
avoir une attitude irréprochable dans
mon travail si elle sanctionne aussi en
faute il ya sanction et ça c'est valable
pour tout le monde je pense parce que
sinon on est garant de la loi et la loi
on n'y touche pas on va poser la
question à laurent croizier alors pour
ou contre cette présomption de légitime
défense type de présomption d'innocence
qui régit le dossier assez légitime
légal iml le principe de présomption
d'innocence qui régit notre notre cadre
légal d'une certaine façon ils répondent
à cette question donc je suis pas sûr
que moi ça nécessite une disposition
légale supplémentaires par contre moi je
veux leur réaffirmer toute ma confiance
parce que la police elle a besoin de
savoir que ces citoyens ou confiance en
elle et d'ailleurs l'immense majorité
des citoyens vis et guilavogui pas
clairement je vais viser les propos de
monsieur mélenchon qui sont absolument
scandaleux qui m'ont outré je signale
juste que jean-luc mais le chef de file
a déclaré la police tue mais c'est le
chef de file de cette alliance d'extrême
gauche dont on parlait tout à l'heure et
alors moi j'ai une pensée aussi pour la
jeune femme qui a été tuée
malheureusement et soit avoir une pensée
pour elle mais utiliser un drame
utiliser la défiance entre la police et
les français à des fins électorales mais
c'est absolument scandaleux ça participe
pas du tout à l'apaisement français et
en plus ça démontre une chose ça
démontre ya quand même un problème entre
monsieur mélenchon et les candidats de
lannux d'extrême gauche avec la
république avec les lois et avec cette
volonté d'apaiser la société française
alors tiens lui qui je peux si je peux
me permettre d'intervenir deux secondes
je suis pas d'accord avec mon camarade
puisqu'il donne confiance à l'ats la
police nationale néanmoins au dernier
beauvau de la sécurité qui est sorti
trois semaines avant les présidentielles
monsieur le président macron à d'essayer
décidé de créer encore un nouveau
mouvement le mouvement de l'assemblée
qui lui rend encore contrôler la police
nationale donc dans un premier temps
vous leur donnez effectivement votre
confiance mais dans un domaine comme
dans un deuxième temps vous crée encore
une institution de contrôle ils sont
déjà suffisamment contrôlée par
antagoniste avec la confiance on va
faire et pourquoi
alors moi je pense que effecto est ce
que jean luc mélenchon qui dit la police
tue au lendemain d'un drame comme ça
alors qu aucune charge n'est retenue
contre ces policiers c'est quoi c'est un
dérapage ou c'est un dérapage contrôlé
le jeu vérifier une vise justement une
partie de l'électorat maintenant je vais
répondre à votre question mais d'âge
d'abord je vais remettre les choses en
perspective
je pense qu'il faut refondre
effectivement la police de la cave au
grenier et nous on est pour une police
de proximité on est pour des gardiens de
la paix et non pas d'une des gardiens de
la paix c'est à dire qu'ils sont un
service public et qui vont maintenir le
droit à la sûreté qui est un droit
fondamental rappelons-nous dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen pour tout le monde nous on est
pour la suppression aussi de la
politique du chiffre qui fait
effectivement que les policiers vont
s'occuper de petits délits au lieu de
s'occuper des trafiquants comme j'en
parlais tout à l'heure maintenant une
fois qu'on a dit ça ya aussi la
formation des policiers à revoir c'est
une formation de six mois nous on veut
remettre une formation de deux ans avec
une formation continue et ça c'est
fondamental effectivement il ya des
conditions de travail dans certains
commissariats qui sont absolument unique
maintenant qu'on a 10 quand on a dit ça
on a un problème dans ce pays deux
politiques de maintien de l'ordre ce
n'est pas normal qu'après un refus
d'obtempérer
la personne soit décédée un refus
d'obtempérer c'est une infraction c'est
un délit qui est puni par la loi de deux
ans d'emprisonnement et de jim 10000
euros d'amendé ce n'est pas la peine de
mort ça fait quatre mois en quatre mois
nous avons eu quatre morts quatre morts
pour refusant d'obtempérer je rappelle
que la peine de mort n'existe l'on va
faire et elle j'ai fini juste je finirai
terminé que vous êtes en très très en
avance en temps de parole c'est en
aurait pu vous n'aurez pas la parole a
donc je considère donc je conte
personnes qui renoncent en jeu
concernant ce n'est pas ça je lis son
laser monsieur je défends la loi et
l'application de la loi et effectivement
il ya un problème de maintien de l'ordre
dans ce pays on n'a pas à gaz et des
voyageurs qui attendent leur train gare
de l'est on n'a pas à gaz et non plus
des personnes qui vont au stade de
france et on n'a pas à tuer des gens
pour refus d'obtempérer il ya la loi on
applique la loi monsieur on applique la
loi monsieur mais si on a plus assez de
fonctionnaires pour garantir l'ordre si
on a remplacé l'homme par des gaz
lacrymo le tas le flash-ball on assiste
à ces dérapages je crois que le rôle de
l'élu c'est aussi de réconcilier ces
forces de police qui sont un autre
service de nos quotidiens de la
population et la population est
d'ailleurs ils sont issus de la
population donc il faut quand même que
nous élus on apaise les choses parce que
le pays va mal les tensions augmentent
et on arrive à des drames de cette
nature je voudrais juste justement quand
on parle des problèmes de sécurité
certains d'entre vous par le prévention
éducation et vous voulez même donc
relier sécurité et éducation alors
quelles sont les solutions vous allez
proposer l'école chute elle son rôle et
les parents joue-t-il le leur je vous
propose d'écouter donc un responsable de
l'association paris qui oeuvrent à
planoise 400 familles sont adhérentes à
cette association qui donc est connu
pour ses actions de soutien scolaire et
d'accompagnement des parents nous
écoutons l'un de ses responsables alors
ma question portera sur les emplois
aidés ces emplois aidés qui avait été
supprimé il ya quelques années qui ont
été remis en place quelques mois plus
tard au niveau de l'association paris
ces emplois aidés on les utilise
principalement en tant qu adulte poste
adulte relais qui sont très importants
pour le monde associatif
ma question est simple quelle est la
politique que vous allez mettre en place
pour pérenniser ses emplois du temps
relais et qui n'est pas cette
incertitude d'une année sur l'autre au
niveau de ses emplois merci laurent
croizier c'est à vous que je vais poser
la question puisque vous représentez ici
la majorité présidentielle comment
pérenniser ces emplois aidés qui ont été
bien utiles à certaines associations sur
le terrain alors sont des emplois qui
ont été effectivement utile mais
c'étaient des emplois qui étaient
précaires donc là il demande justement
de les pérenniser initialement c'était
c'était des emplois qui étaient publics
est donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
on peut pas continuer à capitaliser sur
ces emplois maintenant je on est dans
une période après que vides ya beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé on s'aperçut
cavaillé gros soucis dans l'hôpital
aujourd'hui on a une crise des vocations
à l'hôpital on a une crise des vocations
à l'école on a une crise des vocations
aussi une erreur dans la police c'est la
terreur il faut commencer comment on
continue on continue à soutenir ces
associations qui ont un rôle absolument
fondamental
donc il ya la préfecture cadets font
exactement il va falloir maintenir des
fonds de la préfecture dans le cadre des
politiques
de la ville et puis il va falloir créer
un cadre législatif plus favorable à ce
qu'on puisse aider soutenir financer ces
emplois ces emplois du quotidien et ça
nécessite juste quelque chose ça
nécessite que l'état et des rentrées
fiscales donc ça nécessite aussi une
croissance de façon à pouvoir distribuer
équilibré partagé cet argent en
direction des associations fabrice
galpin pour reconquête concrètement je
pense qu'il faut effectivement renforcer
l'association que paris qui pour moi
fait un excellent travail les devoirs le
soir c'est parfait alors qu'aujourd'hui
on sait très bien que les deux parents
travaillent je préfère que les jeunes
soient même quand les parents
travaillent par les parents travaillent
pas mais pour les parents qui
travaillent qui rentre tard du travail
je préfère que les autres et des enfants
soient à la sociaux paris à faire lors
de voir à travailler à s'assimiler
plutôt que dans la rue bien évidemment
je ce monsieur il faudrait renforcer ses
moyens bien évidemment messieurs 8 pour
le rassemblement national écoutez toute
association qui font un bon travail doit
être un bon travail doit être soutenu
cela dit je me permets de revenir un
tout petit peu avant parce que j'ai pas
pu donner ma conclusion on pourra
remettre tout l'argent qu'on veut dans
les associations dans leurs innovations
combler il dit s'il n'y a pas une
réponse ferme de la loi et je suis
désolé votre garde des sceaux hommes se
croisent y est une une personne qui ne
correspond pas absolu du tout est ce
qu'il faudrait qu'on ait aujourd'hui
vous parlez vous de 2,4 mort le ma foi
aujourd'hui le nombre de crimes long
d'incivilité c'est pas 4 morts depuis
quelques mois c'est beaucoup plus donc
je le répète on pourra mettre tout ce
qu'on veut dans le quartier et des
associations si elles font du bon
travail c'est une chose tant qu'il n'y
aura pas une réponse ferme qui peut vous
paraître violente mais qui est ferme de
la police avec les moyens nécessaires et
avec une réponse derrière de la justice
eh ben vous oublié quelque chose c'est
que vous donnez pas l'exemple moi je
regrette deux jeunes qui sont arrêtés
deux unités sont arrêtées qui sont
déférés qui vont faire deux mois de
prison ça fait réfléchir les petits
copains voilà temps de vous nier le
problème et l'autre problème également
qu'elle ya une immigration sur planète
c'est quand même très importante mais
effectivement là où il ya des
immigrations la hausse du chômage avec
des gens qui ne comprennent pas le
français faut ramener également de
l'associatif fournit des gens pour aider
ça ça nous coûte très très cher je
rappelle également que l'hôpital c'est
un budget de 260 mille euros pour les
interpelle tous là oui mais c'est les
baïnes aisée réagi
heureusement moi je
je suis une fille issue de l'immigration
qui a grandi nantes n'était populaire et
vous parlez d'exemplarité heureusement
qu'on n'écoute pas vos discours parce
que sinon on y rappelle juste se pendre
il ya des très très belle réussite
monsieur jeu grâce à l'éducation
nationale grâce aux indications
laissées là par les associations
d'éducation populaire grâce à
d'éducation des parents aussi un faut
aussi le reconnaître le tableau n'est
pas si noir que ça et puis en collant
des étiquettes comme vous faites vous le
remettez en cause de sa tête sous l'eau
on va demander à ses vrais attendez je
suis très rapidement vol j'ai commencé
ma carrière professionnelle dans
l'éducation populaire donc je connais le
bien fondé de ces associations emplois
aidés non faut arrêter il faut des vrais
emplois des emplois qualifiés d emplois
bien rémunérés
parce qu'il faut un vrai travail là il
faut qu'on se donne les moyens c'est la
priorité je pense être mettre des moyens
dans l'humain investir c'est les
enfoncer les citoyens de demain que ce
soit dans l'éducation nationale que ce
soit dans l'éducation populaire là je
crois qu'on doit avoir une vraie
ambition pour compenser les fragilités
pour compenser le travail des parents
pour compenser aussi une société qui
aujourd'hui va mal je vous arrête parce
que là vous êtes en train d'exploser
votre chronomètre séverine visite vous
êtes déjà très en avance donc je vous
demande d'être très brève sur cette
question je vais faire brève alors
effectivement il faut absolument
soutenir des associations comme
l'association paris qui fait un travail
formidable mais plus gobain ou plus
globalement pardon il faut reconstruire
notre école publique qui a été
particulièrement malmenées comme tous
les services publics par le quinquennat
qui vient de se terminer réduire les
effectifs partout on ne peut les
notamment dans tout ce qui est pré
élémentaire l'itie professionnels l'un
d'eux des quartiers pour prioritaire il
faut reconstruire les réseaux des deux
les rased que le gouvernement a supprimé
puisque ils ont fait des dédoublements
pour les cp cetera mais c'est au
détriment des autres niveaux et ensuite
en prenant des moyens notamment au rabot
du notamment dans les réseaux dette non
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que j'ai fait
pour le dédoublement mais avec des
moyens supplémentaires pas à moyens
constants et s'il ya des salles à dire
entre vous et nous la plus grosse
réussite du quinquennat macron c'est
justement le ddo l'intimé perdre et j'ai
travaillé dix ans à léo dans les écoles
de planoise ya l'enjeu
il faut les temps mon non seulement les
instituteurs non seulement la dslite et
j'y travaille et plein de moi j'ai
travaillé bien sûr mais je suis fait
lundi donc je sais comment ça vous
n'êtes pas au premier degré alors je
crois que vous
non salies mane et sa reine s'il vous
plaît vous laisser parler monsieur
croizier qu'il aille au moins jusqu'à la
fin de son idée et il vous plaît laissez
passer pour la première fois madame
bédié pour la première fois on a
quasiment 100% tcp qui arrive à lire à
la fin de l'année ça c'est fait c'était
du jamais vu maintenant sa cellule
rendez vous rendez un compte dans ces
quartiers prioritaires et on a une
qualité de travail on a des enseignants
qui disent on a des journées enseignants
apaisé si oui mais ce que vous côtoyez
madame madame des
citoyens se sont plaint qu'ils avaient
plus de salles d'arts plastiques pour
pouvoir et ben moi je préfère des
enfants qui savent lire écrire et
compter plutôt que d'avoir une salle
dame est moins cher qu'on la verra les
du collège
vous êtes déjà très en avance mais
mesdames sur votre temps de parole on va
quand même laissé comme un peu de place
aux hommes et dames s'il vous plaît on
passe au dernier thème de cette émission
de ce débat à savoir l'environnement et
on commence directement histoire de
gagner du temps par cette question posée
par philippe caubère les représentants
de l'association sos loué rivières
comtoises on écoute
la loue dont une partie du cours et sur
votre circonscription est à l'agonie
n'héberge plus que 20 % de son potentiel
piscicole théorique c'est sans doute la
dernière législature où il sera possible
d'inverser la tendance
alors je vous pose cette question des
poissons meurent dans la loue dans ses
taux qu'une partie de la population bois
ou des enfants se baignent vont se
baigner c'est pourquoi nous aimerions
connaître les actions précises et
concrètes que vous entendez initiés ou
soutenir afin de sauver la rivière de
gustave courbet marcel aymé bernard
clavel et bien d'autres encore
un patrimoine culturel historique
naturel et touristique d'exception dont
vous aurez la charge et vous êtes élu
allez on commence avec vous fabrice
galpin pour reconquête parce que c'est
vous le petit dernier de la classe g les
chronomètres là qui s'affiche alors
concrètement attention je veux des
mesures concrètes réalistes comment
sauver nos rivières en général la loue
en particulier alors il faut d'abord
pour sauver nos rivières et la loue en
particulier comme vous le dites il faut
déjà faire un gros effort vers l'est
vers nos agriculteurs je sais qu'on les
a beaucoup sollicités ces dernières
années notamment inclus au glyphosate
mais je pense qu'il faut aller encore
plus loin faut réellement avoir un
consensus avec eux et travaillé sur le
premier produit qu'ils peuvent utiliser
et le produit qui en retour vous parle
santé des rivières le premier public que
vous visez sont les agriculteurs c'est
pas forcément le premier public que je
vise il ya aussi les entreprises qui
déverse je pense qu'il faut vraiment
avoir beaucoup plus de contrôle et c'est
même pas un contrôle je vous dirais
c'est plutôt un partenariat c'est mettre
tout le monde autour de la table voir ce
qui se fait de bien ce qui se fait de
mal et plus ensemble arrivés à un
consensus pour justement sauver nos
rivières et sauvé nos forêts monsieur
lutte pour le rassemblement national des
agriculteurs aussi sont dans le viseur
comme l'environnement les agriculteurs
qu'on fait des gros efforts qui encore
aujourd'hui vont en faire parce que les
normes européennes et françaises qui
fera joutes dessus font que aujourd'hui
fait un casse-tête et administratifs et
prenez leur défense parce que c'est un
gros réservoir de voix pour vous moi
parce que c'est eux qui nous font vivre
c'est lui qui nous nourrissent donc au
bout d'un moment si vous voulez on peut
quand même pas non plus en permanence
s'attaquer j'allais dire à la poule aux
oeufs d'or du point de vue
l'alimentation je pense que déjà
beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits les
problèmes qui a aujourd'hui ils ont
peut-être d'autres sources moi je veux
bien la pollution vous ne parlez de des
entreprises la dernière c'était quand
même les usines de coutellerie de deux
de saint vite et là je voudrais que tout
le monde prenne sa responsabilité c'est
usine l'été je vous en prie excusez moi
je vous interromps mais je veux
dire c'est cette usine a répondu à des
critères à l'époque d'installation
validé par la préfecture aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que c'est plus les bons alors
faisons tout ce qui est en effet faire
effectivement pour le faire non mais
quand en entreprise on a aussi des
fromageries qui ont été donc très
traduites devant la justice la semaine
dernière parce qu'elle rejetait des
effluents dans la rivière je suis tout à
fait d'accord et
je dis qu'il faut un vrai consensus avec
les partenaires autour d'une table un
consensus est requis il faudrait mettre
les fromages et les agriculteurs du
protectorat tous ensemble travailler et
des gilets et lady gilet pare-balles et
des sacs de sable a besoin de gilets
pare balles quand on est intelligent je
pense qu'on peut discuter avec tout le
monde non je pense que l'agriculture et
puis l'industrie fromagère quand même le
travail déjà aujourd'hui la main dans la
main maintenant effectivement c'était à
nous de regarder les quelques défauts
qui a pu avoir à ce niveau là et les
faire qu ensemble la rivière se porte
bien au moins la halle où effectivement
il ya une alerte qui est donnée par
cette association mais pour la
fréquenter comme chaque été je trouve
que c'est quand même rivière qui est
belle qui n'est pas mal mais il a pas
dit quel danger je termine j'ai dit moi
des poissons gens voient également alors
peut-être pas autant qu'il voudrait
avoir mais il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses qui ont été faits on peut pas
taper en permanence dessus je vous
rappelle cependant j'extrapole un peu
avec dans le 71 ce qui pose beaucoup de
problèmes ce sont plutôt les les usines
de méthanisation saône et loire
seine et marne à zéro alors la loue
c'est avec une réputation quand même
nationale pour sa population voit aussi
color internationale international ça
c'était avant ça c'était longtemps mais
elle est toujours aussi jolie
effectivement on aime aller s'y balader
il faut déclarer l'eau bien commun
il faut que l'état déclare l'eau bien
commun c'est un combat qu'on doit mener
et avoir une priorité sans eux on ne
peut pas vivre de toute façon ça c'est
clair qu'il faut s'en prendre aux
agriculteurs ou pas pas forcément qu aux
agriculteurs c'est pareil il ya des
agriculteurs très vertueux on parlait la
police nationale tout à l'heure il ya
des policiers vertueux il y en a
quelques-uns qu'il faut sanctionner la
les agriculteurs qui ne respectent pas
la loi il faut le faire on a un seul
particulier on a un sol karstique tour
entre n'y a pas de filtre tout va dans
l'eau donc il ya une prise de conscience
avoir un accompagnement à voir et
trouver des solutions la recherche
l'innovation sont anglais sur cette
problématique là qui devient plus
qu'urgente un accompagnement des
agriculteurs des industriels vous avez
du retard et on la veut dépasser votre
chronomètre c'est vrai ne vs dites moi
alors effectivement c'est un sujet
d'actualité vous l'avais dit à une
condamnation la semaine dernière et
rouillée eu un reportage encore hier
d'une pollution art cologne il faut
mettre en perspective le fait que l'eau
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle et oui c'est
un bien commun oui c'est un bien commun
et sel dire qu'il ya certains principes
a posé comme enlever l'eau de la gestion
de la prédation des firmes
multinationales et de la gestion privée
après des mesures concrètes par rapport
à au sujet qui nous est donnée là le
volet pénal à l'heure actuelle le code
de l'environnement est obscur sur ces
questions là par zoom sur l'eau il ya
2000 watts mais actuellement on voit la
justice vendredi avec 4 fromagerie qui
était en ville ça ils ont visiblement
décidé de taper aux portes et à 0,5 ou 1
% des des affaires qui sont réellement
traités et les aides et les magistrats
se plaignent d'une chaussée le fait que
le code de l'environnement n'est pas
suffisamment clair il ya une loi qui
concerne les poissons une loi qui
concerne la faune et la flore c'est très
compliqué le délit d' écocide il faut
prouver que le dommage va durer sept ans
pour pouvoir véritablement carte grise
et les refaire la loi moi je pense qu'il
faut renforcer le volet plaide pénale il
faut renforcer effectivement les
effectifs de police de l'environnement
dans les parquets il faut renforcer
également l'office français de la
biodiversité et il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs parce qu'effectivement le
comté c'est une pépite c'est une pépite
dans notre région et elle se doit d'être
exemplaire et il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs parce qu'effectivement il
ya souvent des problèmes de stations
d'épuration qui ne sont pas calibrés et
qui fait que effectivement il ya des
effluents qui arrive dans la loue donc
il ya un volet pénal renforcer ya
clarifiée il ya un accompagnement et il
ya le service public qui est l'office
national de la biodiversité est ce que
c'est possible de développer l'activité
humaine comme l'agriculture la
fromagerie et c'est sans nuire à
l'environnement qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire tout d'abord se dire que on a une
responsabilité collective on a un joyau
dans notre département dans notre
circonscription on est tous d'accord au
moins sur ce point là c est là il faut
absolument le conserver ça soit l'eau
que ce soit les paysages c'est juste ce
qui fait ce qui fait l'attractivité de
notre notre territoire ce qui fait la
beauté ce qui fait pourquoi on y vit et
concis et qu'on s'y sent bien et on a
une responsabilité collective donc oui
il faut mettre tout le monde autour de
la table il faut que tout le monde
puisse comprendre qu'il a une part de
responsabilité j'ai parlé de collectif
et du coup individuellement cette fois
on a tous une part de responsabilité les
ont parlé tout à l'heure des
agriculteurs on parle des industriels
moi je vais rajouter aussi les boues
des stations d'épuration qu'on ait
pendant les champs donc ça aussi un
impact sur sur la pollution donc on peut
pas cibler tel ou tel c'est il faut tous
nous mettre autour de la table et il va
falloir aussi changer notre modèle notre
façon de fonctionner par rapport à nos
anneaux à nos déchets nos déchets qu'ils
soient les plastiques mais aussi nos
déchets qu'ils soient les boules et
déchets industriels les déchets entre
guillemets agricole on est on est en
place mais on relance des filières de
recyclage ou alors on réfléchit par
exemple sur ces boues de stations
d'épuration à pouvoir faire de la
méthanisation en a parlé mais ça fait ça
fait partie des aspects ou alors de de
les brûler dans des usines
d'incinération et de faire ensuite des
réserves chaleur je veux savoir monsieur
ça monsieur croizier 90% des cours d'eau
sont pollués au post ici et votre votre
gouvernement s'oppose à l'interdiction
des pesticides donc là vous avez fait
des constats de vieillesse laissez moi
finir monsieur brasier laissez moi finir
monsieur x chu en france quand on
voulait c'est moins les mêmes errements
publics sont fichus le monde policé ce
que vous souffrez à thuré suivre et que
je puisse vous répondre mais celle
choisie parce que là vous ne sortiez une
sortie non mais vous nous sortez des
banalités in the dance vous aimez manger
en tant que vous êtes ici mais je suis
en train de vous expliqué monsieur qu'un
autre monde est possible que celui dont
nous proposer qu'il est l'inaction
climatique je rappelle que votre
gouvernement a été condamné par le
tribunal de paris une action non vous
avez été condamné pour une action
climatique monsieur voilà tout ça ce
sont des faits noirci son précédent
mandat d' emmanuel macron qui a failli
sur la politique environnementale
là il nous fait des grandes promesses
mais on doit être vraiment très exigeant
à ce niveau là où gisent léger le 1er
avril un jeu justement juste on va faire
réagir monsieur galles par et monsieur
lutz pour reconquête et pour le
rassemblement national et après
j'appellerai club on you
justement est-ce que d'après vous macron
en a fait trop ou pas assez écoutés nous
l'avons longuement sur l'environnement
nous on a une position que différentes
vous savez qu'on est pour le pour le
localisme on est naturellement contre
les éoliennes qui sont des énergies qui
s'imposent pour nous pas renouvelable
qui en grève seulement l'industrie
allemande on est effectivement pour le
nucléaire quelle énergie propre un qui
devrait être délivrée aux français
d'ailleurs
on prie de sortie du vide c'est-à-dire à
40 euros du mégawatt et non pas avec
l'europe cause à effet du marché unique
on la vend 40 et un objet d'art achetées
300 ce qui fait que les factures
d'énergie vont exploser pour nos
concitoyens donc là-dessus effectivement
nous notre écologie elle est positive
c'est le localisme elle est réelle elle
part pas dans des chimères alors
complètement ahurissante alors vous
écologie et les commet alors moi
déjà je comprends pas monsieur croizier
pourquoi monsieur macron dans les dents
le son dernier quinquennat n'a pas
justement tout mis en place tout mis en
place pour l'environnement et pour moi
l'écologie l'éolien je suis complètement
contre aujourd'hui si on mettait de
l'éolien il faudrait mettre en france 36
milles éoliennes 36000 éoliennes sur
trente six mille éolienne pour supprimer
toutes les centrales actuellement
exactement je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui chaque citoyen ait envie
d'avoir une éolienne dans son jardin
ensuite c'est l'énergie aux liens à
comment à refaire c'est extrêmement
compliqué de revaloriser les éoliennes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
travailler sur d'autres énergies vous
projet les éoliennes c'est difficile à
recycler exactement il faut travailler
aujourd'hui sur l'hydrogène il faut il
faut à trouver une indépendance et cette
indépendance française énergétique elle
ne passera aujourd'hui que par le
nucléaire alors mesdames messieurs chers
téléspectateurs j'appelle maintenant
claude brouillaud se croirait presque
donc à l'eurovision claude bruillot qui
est journaliste à france bleu besançon
et comme promis c'est lui maintenant qui
va vous interrogez pour revenir sur les
éléments du débat sur un certain nombre
de choses bref il va vous titiller un
petit peu et alors claude vous avez
décidé de commencer par salima et des
arènes bonsoir malamine nazarene alors
on est vous l'avez dit vous l'avez tous
répété dans un scrutin qui a une
envergure nationale
si vous n'êtes pas présente au second
tour et que madame vieillesse est elle
qualifiée pour le second tour est ce
qu'il y aura un rapprochement naturel ou
délicats avec nuque
est-ce que vous poserez la question
aussi à madame béziat système en
question ans au second tour
je veux pas la question dans l'hypothèse
vous n'êtes pas au second tour que fait
dans l'hypothèse bat déjà - jeu concours
à cette élection avec
mes partenaires autour de cette table
pour porter un projet auquel je crois
qu'elle est sensiblement différent quand
même de celui de madame bédié s sur
certains points sur d'autres on se
retrouve on verra au second tour ce qui
va se passer mais je compte bien y être
second tour parce qu'il ya quand même
des positions qui sont assez proches
notamment quand on a abordé la question
de la sécurité tout à l'heure on vous
sent quand même relativement proches de
madame béziers s'est alors les
téléspectateurs ne voit peut-être pas
forcément la différence à ce moment là
alors plus proches de madame disent que
le monsieur croizier sur le point de
sécurité je passe en titre aux
différences simplement des retraits
remettre des fonctionnaires
l'éducation populaire et la prévention
là je crois qu'on était tous eu plus ou
moins d'accord sur ce plan-là dit tous
pas les noms de messieurs voilà j'ai
cité madame béziers c'est monsieur
croizier on n'est pas d'accord avec
monsieur lutz et monsieur galpin ça je
vous l'assuré
nous verrons bien la configuration de ce
second tour comment comment il se
profilera il faudra aussi des
engagements forts notamment sur la
question européenne et des valeurs de la
république monsieur galpin est à vous si
j'ose dire claude alors que monsieur mal
qu'un monsieur gaga pardon on s'est
rencontré il ya quelques semaines
lorsque vous aviez présenté donc vos
candidats dans le département et vous
m'aviez dit pour france bleu besançon
c'est pas parce que je suis à reconquête
que je fais pas de social et là vous
avez abordé la question du social de
manière assez générales alors c'était
intéressant mais peut-être pas assez
précise que vous pourriez préciser les
propos quand on parle par exemple de
planoise qu'est ce que vous faites dans
le domaine du social précisément alors
depuis les années soixante dix il ya dix
plans dits plan social qui ont été faits
sur planoise il y a plusieurs
millions d'euros qui ont été données sur
planoise et on se rend bien compte
aujourd'hui que ça n'a servi à rien
mettre de l'argent comme ça ne sert
effectivement à rien par contre quand je
vois une association comme paris
effectivement kiki qui pleure de ne pas
avoir suffisamment de personnel eh bien
oui il faut redonner du personnel je
suis pour le social je ne suis pas pour
l'assistanat mais rebelle du personnel
il faut de l'argent ab bien sûr qu'il
faut de l'argent mais aujourd'hui
l'argent qu'on met à planoise esquissé
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qui
sert tous les rodéos urbains qui ont
lieu tous les dimanches ça n'en est pas
là sur le social là on est au dessus
assure la sécurité gens comme lui dit
remettre du personnel quitte à créer des
emplois de fonctionnaires alors quitte à
créer des emplois de fonctionnaires oui
il faut des gens qui soit c'est pas
forcément ce que dit eric zemmour 1
après il ya déjà des grandes lignes moi
je vous connais mon secteur je vois que
planoise il faut du monde il faut des
éducateurs il faut aider il ne faut pas
un sou poudre et d'argent en permanence
ça ne sert à rien ça ne sert à rien je
vais prendre par exemple un exemple
social actuellement qui me qui me tient
à coeur c'est le restaurant l'entracte à
besançon qui actuellement à un jeune qui
travaille chez lui qui s'appelle mamadou
un jeune guinéen et bien ce jeune il a
reçu une oqtf il n'y a pas très
longtemps obligation de quitter le
territoire français voilà une chute et f
qui a pas très longtemps ce jeune c'est
une valeur pour la france il faut le
garder
néanmoins tous les choufs effectivement
qui sont à l'honneur tous ceux qui ont
une économie souterraine à planoise non
il faut sévir donc vous êtes pour du
social pas de ce que je subis social
modérés tout simplement on écoutera
monsieur lutz réponse peut-être à ce
point de vue vous pouvez continuer
claude est justement basse et thomas
luxe derrière allez y on reste à
planoise monsieur lutz chef d'entreprise
vous avez abordé la question de la
sécurité de manière assez ferme arts se
mérite de la franchise vous dites il
faut sanctionner immédiatement la
seconde chance pour vous ça existe pas
la prison elle est là déjà pour isoler
pour protéger les citoyens d'un dealer
qui peut avoir des armes chez lui qui
peut faire comme le dif et magazines
tout à l'heure faire que les gens
puissent plus descendre de leur cage
d'escalier ou qu'à certaines vers une
piste rouge et donc je veux dire cette
personne n'at il faut déjà la mettre en
prison pour le bien des citoyens
deuxièmement effectivement le délit qui
selon vous est passible de prison si
c'est juste squatter au pied de
l'immeuble intelligence je vais pas me
faire j'en avais la loi est là je veux
dire une et délits je pense qu'on en aa
fait pour que les les problèmes qui à
planoise soit largement traitée par les
magistrats le problème c'est qu'il faut
que les magistrats aient la volonté de
fer sur le saunier tout à l'heure le
gouvernement macron un bilan nul et même
mauvais je vous reprends sur ce thème la
volonté aux moyens alors je pense que
déjà il ya une question de volonté vous
voulez les moyens il ya des policiers
qui aujourd'hui ont besoin de plus de
moyens de devoir de j'allais dire la
possibilité de se dé se défendre comme
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure plus de moyens
matériels également humain mais derrière
si vous mettez dix policiers pour
courser dit dealer de drogue et puis que
au bout d'une heure à la gare d'eau ils
sont relâchés et puis qu'ils rentrent
chez eux laguerre règlement pour ceux
qui ne sont pas sur besançon c'est le
commissariat de bezouce n'est pas que
france 3 et des mois de ce grand
continent
voilà effectivement si ces dealers au
bout de deux heures sont de nouveau de
retour dans leur quartier excusez moi en
petits caïds et en roi est pas ça sert à
rien de mettre des moyens dans la police
il faut que la loi force doit rester à
la loi est la loi doit être appliquée et
puis la prison est là pour faire
réfléchir les délinquants voyez je suis
même pour un prix un modèle de prison à
l'achat ce n'est pas la notion de
seconde chance
parce que la prison si vous voulez
aujourd'hui la prison malheureusement
elle rend les gens plus mauvais la
prison elle devrait être vertueuse c'est
le principe de la prison républicaine
elle n'est pas appliquée aujourd'hui moi
je vais vous dire qu'au japon dans une
prison quelques exemplaires parce qu'on
vous isole pendant 15 jours ou quatre
semaines et pendant quinze jours aux
quatre semaines vous regardez pas la
télé vous êtes face à votre vie pourquoi
vous en êtes là votre compte axer notre
avocat qui vous explique pourquoi parce
qu'on l'associé de retraite spirituelle
non mes côtés mais il ya un moment il
faut quand même que les gens soient face
à la situation dans laquelle ils sont
mis on peut pas excuser en permanence
tout le monde c'est trop facile de dire
quand il était jeune il a voulu une
belle voiture dont qu'il allait braquer
les gens où il y avait volée mais il ne
faisait pas il le faisait pour ses
copains et tout non je regrette la loi
je suis et je termine là dessus nous en
tant que chef d'entreprise on n'a pas
droit à une seconde chance moi ma tv
asyl 25 l ai pas fait gilles 10% moi si
je me trompe dans le cas des embauches
j'ai la pénalité et au besoin en tant
que chef d'entreprise si un employé ce
bref parce que je n'ai pas donné les
équipements ou qu'il a fait une erreur
mais que je suis responsable c'est moi
qui peut aller en prison alors vous avez
une danse gym n'allait pas en prison je
vais en prison également scénarisé non
mais renseignez vous également un petit
peu il ya eu un accident dans une
industrie où les racks sont tombés avec
le charisme ce chef d'entreprise ce soir
était sans lacets en cellule leurs
valises les gens en asie les gens
honnêtes une fédération juste faire
réagir messieurs galpin justement sur ce
que dit monsieur lutte vous vous parlez
prévention sociale est ce que vous êtes
d'accord à vox avec ce discours de la
droite de la droite on va dire alors je
suis juriste à peu près d'accord avec
cela je suis à peu près d'accord avec le
discours de monsieur lutz mais avant
tout je pense qu'il faut éduquer faire
une prévention et si effectivement en
l'enfant je dirais ne comprends pas
effectivement là on peut le mettre en
prison il faut effectivement verbalisé
par contre il faut donner à nos
fonctionnaires le moyen de sévir et le
moyen de verbaliser aujourd'hui les
fonctionnaires de police sont ils vont
au travail le matin il s'est fait en
disant je vais tuer quelqu'un comme le
dit monsieur mélenchon il se lève pas
comme ça mais il se dit je vais faire
mon travail et ils partent
malheureusement avec la boule au ventre
parce qu'ils savent pas si le soir ils
vont être en garde à vue ou non je
parlais tout à l'heure des rodéos qui
partent de planoise et qui font le tour
des boulevards aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
un policier qui intervient parce que si
malheureusement il percute quelqu'un
qu'il fait tomber quelqu'un ce sera le
policier qui rend garde à vue encore
qu'il faut déjà une éducation une
prévention et ensuite effectivement
c'est là où je rejoins monsieur luce
aucun il faut c'est bien aucun de nous
deux ne déplore quand même le manque
d'éducateurs spécialisés l'a écouté
[Musique]
la mission
arrêtez de
le laisser parler madame comme des
cévennes s'il vous plaît avant sur moi
vous savez que nous on a fait campagne
sur le pack de la ruralité et le
bouclier rural or monsieur bouclier
rural dans les coudes quand sur s'invite
sur saint vite sur aux deux sur
buissière mais pas les millions qu'on
déverse à planoise et vous arrêtez
révisé largement temps vous devant tant
de paroles moi je salue mais vrai que
vous avez d'abord
monsieur vous demeure atone et jusqu'à
ce que vous pouvez est ce que pouvait
juste aussi être un petit peu moins
violent parce qu'en fait vous êtes une
violence qui est assez incroyable alors
souffre et qu'une femme puisse vous
répondre et vous parlez des fonds la
vérité non seulement je m'entends
baguenauder francs contre l'asvel
emmenée par aplats noirs
salima et les arènes vous avez la danse
aussi peu d'espacé autant de population
avec autant de fragilité faut pas
s'attendre à des miracles vous parlez si
vous voulez qu'on parlait réalité elle
est là aussi vous parler je finisse
merci c'est gentil oui justement et
c'est pour ça qu'on met des politiques
publiques aussi dans les campagnes et
heureusement si vous faites les ratio
par habitant il est équivalent non si
vous parlez vous balancer des millions
mais ya plus de personnes d'abia sûr et
heureusement je le sais et c'est pour ça
qu'on a été élu le fait qu'il ait lui
aussi grâce à nos politiques il
s'intéresse à l'état serait vraiment de
dire aussi que la première
circonscription du doubs ne se résume
pas planoise il ya beaucoup de ruralité
qui a de grands questionnements sur la
ruralité notamment les questions de
service public et je regrette qu'on
n'ait pas non plus parler de pouvoir
d'achat d'hôpital de service public de
transports publics elle s'est consacrée
déjà j'ai 1h10 pour s'étirer sais rien
mais on a d'ailleurs on va de trois
unités on a beau va de sécurit ville
parce que c'est quand même on est à même
la circonscription de franche comté
c'est vouloir c'est terminé ma phrase
qui connaît le plus de problèmes d'ouïe
grille mais on a aussi vécu on commence
à voir gâcher la parole alors aux
rouilles aussi ça vous dérange pas
madame vs voulez à tout saisir une
petite seconde
moi je suis surpris de ce que j'entends
sur planoise de la part de ces deux
dames parce que quand mes équipes
militantes alors dix fois les coller à
planoise elles ne veulent pas y aller
parce qu'elle me dise clairement
planoise c'est plus la république on va
se faire attaquer on va se faire
agresser on l'est ne veulent pas y aller
et ça n'est pas normal proposer sa
petite question maintenant à laurent
croizier oui et malheureusement on va
rester sur planoise parce que c'est
l'actualité du moment et on n'a pas
entendu monsieur croizier là dedans ces
derniers échanges monsieur croizier vous
avez dit tout à l'heure c'était
intéressant sur la sécurité il faut plus
de bleus sur le terrain
qu'est ce que vous dites aux policiers
bisontins qui pour certains d'ailleurs
pour préserver leur sécurité ne monte
pas dans les cages d'escalier dans les
immeubles parce qu'ils sont pères de
famille tout simplement qu est ce que
vous leur dites mal informés ils vont
dans les cages des n'auriez pas si les
policiers municipaux ils vont vous savez
qu'il ya eu en mai mais jamais je peux
vous avez eu un cambriolage il ya trois
semaines nombre de postes à planoise et
les policiers saumon et ceux là sont
montés ils ont interpellé je vous dire
que les policiers n'ont pas peur d'aller
à planoise hiziv on initie
bouclier qui peut
le moi je vous assure qu'en allant
régulièrement et au pardon sur le
terrain tous les policiers
non il faut pas avoir peur d'aller on
peut à la planoise moi il m'arrive
d'aller à 22h en costard cravate et ne
craint ne rien craindre il ya 99 couleur
de peau le lien que 99% des agréments de
salon à ce qu'ils sont les eaux lors des
gens qu'elle ne versons pas noté mémoire
sont pas lavés telus où il est élu oui
qu'est ce que vous dites aux policiers
bisontins quel discours vous le retenait
mais mais mais je le redis il faut il
faut il ne faut pas voir non je leur dis
même pas il faut ne pas avoir peur ils y
vont à planoise donc non votre question
vous leur dire quoi alors eh ben je leur
dise on va juste vous simplifier les
procédures administratives pour que
plutôt que vous soyez dans votre bureau
à remplir des formulaires vous puissiez
aller faire votre travail et c'est ce
qu'ils demandent ils veulent redonner du
sens à leur travail leur travail il est
où leur gré de la moyens nation je leur
donne évidemment plus de moyens mais
yat-il normes et énormément de moyens
qui ont été faits mais ils ont besoin
aussi que la justice suive ça a été dit
tout à l'heure et on redonne des moyens
le justice de façon à ce qu'on puisse
établir toute la justice j'ai repris
tout à l'heure monsieur lutte manque de
volonté manque de moyens d'un manque de
moyens le budget de la justice a été
augmentée 30% c'est c'est historique il
faut il va falloir une attachée il avoir
un magistrat et là 300 dossiers sur son
bureau vous croyez qui peut qui peut
agir donc on a déjà créé 7000 postes de
justice auprès des cinq dernières années
on va continuer on va créer 8500 poste
de magistrat être personnels de justice
tu pour aider sur 7 sur cette continuité
de chaîne pénale donc on à l'éducation
les éducateurs qui sont très importants
mais moi je rejoins ce que ce qu'a dit
madame sy nazareth les éducateurs ils
servent pas ou 1% qui sont malhonnêtes
ode aux dealers dans ils servent à 99%
la population ils sont très importantes
dans la rue et y en a pas assez et y en
a pas assez
pourquoi un enfant mais pas ceux où vous
dire la délinquance l'exil les besoins
je parle pas lui-même donc l'école les
éducateurs et puis évidemment il faut il
faut la répression donc les policiers et
derrière il faut une réponse pénale
quand quand il ya une infraction qui
économistes et cette réponse pénale on
permet aux juges de pouvoir la prison
quand les prisons sont déjà remplis à
120% fait comment eh ben on recrée des
prisons c'est dans le programme du
président macron puisque en 2027 entre
2010 et 2025 il y aura eu quinze mille
objets sont les deux plongeons pour
répondre en renvoie les dix mille
prisonniers qui n'ont qu'ils sont
illégaux on les renvoie dans leur pays
tout simplement ça va déjà libéré dix
mille places un club que je vous promets
une prison au maroc comme en turquie
fait pas la prison en france
pour dire sur la question d'avant de
monsieur les policiers n'ont pas peur
d'aller à planoise non absolument pas
peur d'y aller par contre effectivement
je peux complètement comprendre qu'ils
ne veulent pas y aller parce que les
gens qu'ils arrêtent à 22h à 23h ils
sont dehors donc vous allez interroger
maintenant séverine visuel voilà madame
béziers est donc pour terminer
accompagner les agriculteurs vous avez
dit sur la question environnementale la
protection de nos rivières
préserver la pépite la filière comptait
donc les fabricants ce qu'il faut pas
sanctionner aussi parfois alors j'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait un volet
pénal a clarifié un joli dit faut donner
des moyens à l'office nationale pour la
biodiversité
il faut renforcer la police
environnementale dans les parquets mais
néanmoins effectivement il faut un
processus d'accompagnement mais pas que
la filière comté nous on est pour une
agriculture paysanne locale biologique
parce qu'il faut assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire et moi je suis
effectivement pour développer une
agriculture locale paysanne et non pas
avec un modèle agricole avec une
agriculture intensive ça veut dire aussi
agir au mieux on va faire du bio j'ai
pas dit du bio déjà si on fait de la
dite biologique non d'accord mais ça
veut dire que c'est pas forcément dire
que les trois termes sont alignés il
faut qu'on aille vers un modèle
d'agriculture biologique j'ai visité la
ferme du barbant à pelousey qu
absolument exemplaire deux jeunes qui se
sont installés les jeunes ont beaucoup
de mal à s'installer un problème de
foncier aussi donc en fait il ya tout
une question à traiter et il ya la
question de la politique agricole
commune qui favorise les grosses
exploitations
nous on est pour réorienter la politique
agricole commune plutôt sur des
questions de sûreté sur des fermes avec
forte main-d'oeuvre et non pas forcément
sur des questions d'hectares pour evi
éviter en fait ce cette concentration
jusqu'à maintenant depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est justement
une agriculture intensive qui nous a
permis d'être autonome en nourriture en
alimentation mais il ne vous aura pas
échappé que la guerre est finie non pas
de la fin de la belle avancée non il ne
vous aura pas échappé qu'on est face à
un enjeu planétaire qui est le
réchauffement climatique que notre
souveraineté alimentaire est en danger
que justement comme vous le dites très
bien les événements en ukraine montre
effectivement que notre indépendance en
matière notamment alimentaires et
industriels pose problème et
effectivement il faut relocaliser la
production et il faut assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire et puis il ya
la queue on en a parlé tout à l'heure la
loue etc il faut vivre avec notre
écosystème on en a qu'un il faut le
préserver et nous on prêt on porte la
règle verte qui est quoi la rue levert
on ne prélève pas à la nature plus que
ce qu'elle ne peut reconstituer c'est le
b à ba mais ce cas pas aussi à un
équilibre à trouver qu visiblement on
recherche encore aujourd'hui notamment
du côté de la justice entre le respect
des règles qui sont parfois très
compliqué à comprendre et aussi
permettre aux entrepreneurs aux
fabricants de continuer à vivre et à se
développer parce qu'il donne du travail
aux gens d'ici mais bien sûr mais je
crois que savoir une dernière réunion ne
soit pas d'abus dans un discours quand
je parle de l'office national de la
biodiversité ce sont des ce sont des
opérateurs publics qui peuvent
accompagner et nous on est pour par
exemple faire une caisse de défaisance
pour les agriculteurs qui assurerait
cette conversion de leur agriculture et
leur modèle agricole noqui on accompagne
juste merci beaucoup claude ce sera
votre dernière question juste une chose
on vous n'a posé une question à ce film
à illzach n est pas vous si madame idées
à rennes est devant et qualifier au
deuxième tour et pas vous est ce que
vous appeler à voter pour elle alors moi
je fais campagne pour gagner pour
remporter cette circonscription et pour
qu'on ait 289 vous avez confié la même
rêvé pour aînés 2 189 députés parce que
c'est l'enjeu imposer une cohabitation
emmanuel mach 2 189 députés actuellement
le groupe note de l'amoureuse insoumise
avec tous ses partenaires à moins de 70
députés donc maintenant est arrivée
l'heure de la conclusion on respecte le
même ordre de passage que tout début de
cette émission laurent croizier vous
avez 30 secondes allez encore deux
secondes top chrono c'est à vous alors
dimanche nous renouvelons l'assemblée
nationale c'est un grand moment de
démocratie et moi j'ai envie de dire aux
citoyens qui nous écoutent et aux
citoyennes c'est que dimanche il va
falloir voter pour va falloir voter pour
des députés un député responsable
pour un député qui sera être proche de
vous qui saura traiter les enjeux qui
sont extrêmement importants car en son
pouvoir d'achat je pense au plein emploi
je pense aux valeurs la république je
pense au progrès social au progrès
écologique et je vous propose de voter
pour une france forte pour une france
merci merci l'europe très bien merci
beaucoup fabrice galpin 30 secondes
c'est à vous alors vous l'aurez compris
autour de cette table je suis le seul
candidat des droites et je suis un homme
d'engagement le aux élections prochaines
au vote prochain vous aurez trois choix
le premier c'est de voter pour une
candidate islamo gauchistes qui rêvent
de livrer notre pays à ceux qui n'aiment
pas le deuxième choix ce sera un des
députés qu'ils n'appuieront que sur le
bouton et enfin le troisième choix ce
sera un homme d'engagement à un homme de
conviction un homme de valeur un homme
de droite celui que je suis et je
souhaite par cette sélection devenir le
député de la première circonscription du
doubs et redonner de la parole à ceux
qui ne l'ont plus
séverine vieillesse c'est à vous alors
moi je voudrais dire qu'un autre chemin
est possible que celui qu'on a vécu
pendant ces cinq années on a on peut
avoir des députés qui vont voter pour le
pouvoir d'achat qui vont voter pour des
services publics qui vont voter pour la
bifurcation écologique et je serai 7
députés qui votera pour offrir d un
changement de vie aux citoyens et aux
citoyennes de circonscrire de cette
circonscription et puis je voudrais dire
qu'on est dans un troisième tour et
qu'on est face à un moment historique
avec le rassemblement de l'ensemble de
la gauche et des écologistes pour pour
cette élection et que véritablement non
seulement on peut faire barrage à
maquereau mais en plus on peut mettre en
place un programme vertueux mais risque
d'une stratégie et démocratique les 12
et 19 le bulletin radio coup c'est lé v
de la victoire s'anima inea n 30
secondes pour vous je représente la
gauche républicaine démocratique et
sociale celle qui est attentive à la
cohésion de la nation et à ses services
publics je suis volontaire sans être
sectaire réformiste sans être irréaliste
j'ai chevillée au corps la lutte contre
les inégalités qui ronge notre société
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique qui devient plus qu'urgente
élu député je siègerai dans un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale qui votera ce qui
est bon pour le pays et ses habitants
qui à mandera ce qui est insuffisant
vous finirez robes douces et agréables
qui est contraire à ses valeurs pour une
gauche européenne votée salies mane les
arènes et didier aubry
monsieur lutz pour le rassemblement
national vous êtes le dernier à vous
exprimer pour cette conclusion nous
épluchons le vote pour le rassemblement
final dimanche douce et dimanche 19 va
permettre à des députés de vous protéger
de protéger votre pouvoir d'achat en
baissant la tva notamment sur les
carburants et sur les énergies de 20 à
5,5 je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui sur un 2
litres de gasoil vous donner un euro 30
de taxes au gouvernement qui
effectivement avec 500 milliards de
dette ne peut pas faire autrement fait
également voté contre les déserts
médicaux et la case qui arrive et c'est
voter naturellement pour la sécurité
parce que voyez bien qu'on est dans deux
mondes différents et certains ni les
problèmes qu'il peut y avoir nous nous
serons toujours aux côtés des français
merci beaucoup je vous laisse découvrir
donc les noms des autres candidats
présents sur cette circonscription qui
seront en lice dock pour le premier tour
dimanche je vous laisse découvrir leur
nom est donc leur parti politique et
j'ajoute donc que michel vianey que vous
voyez tout en bas de la liste des
républicains le conseiller départemental
étaient invités à ce débat mais que
souffrant il n'a pas pu être présent
parmi nous merci mesdames merci
messieurs pour eux ce débat merci claude
d'avoir fait le déplacement de la place
granvelle jusque chez nous à la gare
d'eau merci pour votre participation
merci pour votre attention on se donne
rendez vous dimanche n'oubliez pas 19h
dans le journal on parle des élections
et à partir de 20h15 tous les résultats
les réactions et les analyses bonne fin
de soirée à vous et tout de suite le
journal régional
[Musique]
pour